Hey, guys. We're back, and in today's video
we're making another organic silicone mold.
Today's request comes from HorseyTube in the comments.
He asked, "A brain in a silicone mold? Like if you agree!"
With over 361 likes that looks like
this is the experiment we should be doing today.
Now I've actually been wanting to mold a brain for over a month.
Ever since I saw, in Vat 19, these gummy brains
that they have. So I got in touch with the company,
and they sent me a couple of these that
we could use for reference as we're
making a mold here today. So, big
shout-out to Vat 19, thanks for sending
these things to me. They are four pounds,
4,000 calories, and if you wanna look at
getting one for yourself I'll put a link
down in the description that will take you
right to them
[sniffs] like cherry, smells really good.
Now, at first I was thinking it'd be fun to cast one of these
gummy brains in silicon to
make our own gummy brain, but to go one
step further, I got back in touch with a
biology corporation and ordered a couple
of cow brains so the molds we make today
are 100-percent legitimate brain.
And I had to get them online because apparently cow
brains are regulated by the FDA. So let's
open this thing up and see what they look like.
there we go. Okay.  We're seeing this,
together, for the first time.
Apparently there's two cow brains in
there which is ridiculously small. I mean
this package of two cow brains right now
is smaller than one of the VAT 19 gummy
brains by themselves. The difference is,
these are legitimate brains so let's open
the bag up to take a closer look.
Yummy.
Oh, yeah. That's the stuff. Right there
So, same process as last time:  I'm gonna cut this
bag open we're gonna wash these brains
off, and then we're going to take a closer look,
maybe do a little surgery to get them
prepped and ready for our silicon mold.
So yeah, these brains are a little bit smaller than the
VAT 19, but they're a little more
appropriate for serving size as well.
[laughs quietly]
Admittedly, I don't know much about how
the brain works, so I did a quick google
search and this is what i learned this
outer layer covering the brain is
probably part of the meninges, and this
skin we're looking at is part of the peel
layer. This acts is an envelope to
protect the brain and the spinal cord.
That almost sounds like I know what I'm
talking about. How does the brain feel? It's a
little bit spongy, it's firm I feel like
if I push it too hard though I could
squish it. It almost feels like gummy.
It actually feels a lot like gummy.
It actually looks so delicate, that if I
just took my fingers and tugged a little
bit I think it would slip right off now
this layer here –
Oh yeah – Now that's actually a lot
tougher than I was expecting.
I thought this was just slide right off,
but it's actually a really hard skin.
It rips. I'm gonna get my scalpel. My exacto
knife scalpel. [imitates "shing" sound] Oh wow. Look in here.
there's some kind of brown fuzz – brown
fiber. That is really interesting
it's like going down between the layers
of brain now and in the center here, it's kind of
spiney. It's really hard –
Use what you got.
There's chunks of brain flying out everywhere.
That's pretty tough there. That's like
snipping a cable. Use my electrical - (unintelligible) - for that. [tools scrape]
There we go. This is coming off a little bit easier now.
is this considered brain surgery, if I don't put
it back together.  While we're here looking at
this, let's take a quick look at this
brain. So, I imagine what we have over
here is the brain stem... some kind of a... Oh!
You know what these things are that's
from the eyeballs. Oh wow. So all this
fatty stuff is where the eyeballs would
have sat. So here's the cow's head, the
brain, and the eyeballs facing forward–
which would probably make these the
frontal lobes, the temporal lobes, and
then back here is the brain stem, which would lead to the spinal cord.
That's not disgusting at all, is it?
Before I get too far in here, probably better to chop off
these eyeballs.
[laughing] Ew.
That's one of the optical nerves that
would lead to the eyeball, yeah. Actually
look how thick that optical nerve is.
I didn't realize that it was that big. Very
interesting, and instead of seeing a
bunch of electrical cables like you'd see inside a
copper wire or something, it's just... some kind of mush...
some kind of matter. Very spongy, Very cool. I feel like I should be wearing a face mask.
Ok so that's opening up. That's good. Oh
yeah, this is actually encouraging. So,
looking down inside here you can see
between those two pieces of brain, and
it's looking a little more encouraging.
I'm not sure what that piece is that
looks interesting, but it looks like I
can cut it away and I'm actually
interested in these two halves of the
brain here. But, now it's starting to look
a little bit more like a brain here as
we get this peeled away.
We've just got to find a way to disconnect
this last bit i think we're in business.
Oh wow, this just slides right apart
that was easy.
I thought that was going to be super
tough and super thick to get through, but that was super easy. And there
have it. There's our first brain reveal.
Oh no. There's even another layer here
so this must be the peel layer. That pulls
right away and now we get all those
little cracks and crevices and make the
brain look like the brain. Looks like saran wrap, sucked right down in there.
But here's the difference so this one
has a very very fine layer of membrane
over it which I think is the peel layer, and
over here you can see we've removed that
and you can look right down all those
cracks and crevices and maybe even like
gently separate them if you needed to.
This stuff is really soft and mushy. I'm
worried about pushing it too hard
because, you can see, it just turns right
into mush.
Ok. Now, we got this layer here that forms a
nice little envelope all around the
brain and try to gently remove this one
because it looks to be in better tact than
our first brain was. What I realize about this is
that if there ever was a zombie apocalypse
they're gonna have a hard time actually
getting to your brain,
these are not easy. Ooh, look at this. We've
actually preserved quite a bit of it
there we go i think for best results
like more of that skin-y stuff we can get off
the better that this is going to work
because the silicone can seep down into those
grooves a little bit better. It's kinda like after you get a sunburn and
your skin starts peeling [laughs] kinda what that reminds me of.
and that's the stuff looks
like after it's been removed. I would not trust
myself to do real brain surgery. [laughs] It's too bad they did
such a hack job when they sent me these
things. I was hoping maybe a little more
plump, and a little bit better condition
but that's what we've got guys. Two genuine cow
brains and the thing that strikes me is
how small they are.
I would have thought a brain would be
quite a bit bigger than that
but that's what we're looking at just a
nice little fist full of cow brain. So,
kind of creepy, kind of disgusting, kind
of educational, but in any case I think
this is about as good as we're gonna get
them. So, let's go find ourself some plastic
containers, mix up some silicone, and cast
ourselves some new rubber molds.
[music plays]
[thunk]
[music continues]
[air hisses]
alright so, quick update, guys. So what
actually happened when we poured the
first silicon mold, is our brain started
floating up in the silicon, and floated
right to the top, and we can't have that.
So we took the other brain, we held it in
place with a screw from the bottom and
we took all the silicon from the one
container and poured it over the second
brain. So now we have mixed up a second
batch, we've secured the second brain,
and we're pouring that as well. Who knew brains
float in silicone. So, if you try this yourself
make sure you secure it before you start pouring
[Music plays]
there you have it guys. Once
again we made a terrible mess and you
pretty much know the routine by now.
These things are going to need 24 hours to
cure. Now I took a little of the excess
silicone and poured over top of the actual
Vat 19 gummy brain as well, and I'm thinking
that will give us a skin that we could
use to probably clone more of those
gummies in the future as well, if we want to
go with bigger brains. Now, I'm really curious to
see how these molds out because, if they
turn out ok, I'm thinking about taking
green and purple gummi and making edible
zombie brains. What do you think about that?
and I've still got that other Vat 19 gummy
brain that still in its wrapper. I'm
going to give it to one of you and I'm
gonna give it away in my Instagram
stories. So click the link in the
description to follow me on instagram
and look for the secret clue coming in
the next few days and thanks again to
HorseyTube for requesting this experiment in
the comments keep an eye on your youtube
inbox, I'll be sending 25 bucks. Hey, thanks
for joining me for this video guys! It
was one we had to put our brains
into. I'll be looking for you in the
next video, talk to you then. We're gonna make a zombie
brain! That's it! We're gonna make a
zombie brain.
[closing music plays]
[closing music fades]